hablamos de salud en directo américa de
france 24 me acompaña en el estudio
marina sardina marina bienvenida buena
mañana de martes y hablamos de un nuevo
estudio por el centro nacional liderado
por eso internacional de investigaciones
cardiológicas de españa' y publicado en
la revista new england journal of
medicine' destaca como una píldora reus
el 30% marina las muertes
cardiovasculares y que se trata es de
tratamiento que aglutina tres píldoras
en una sierra es una polipíldora que
combina tres medicamentos y que reduce
un 30% la incidencia de mortalidad
dentro de los seis meses posteriores al
infarto de miocardio
se trata de una sola pastilla como
decías compuesta por de estos tres
medicamentos aspirina ramipril un
inhibidor de la enzima convertidora de
angiotensina que relaja las venas y las
arterias para reducir la presión
arterial y también la atorvastatina una
estatina que reduce el colesterol el
estudio incluye un total de 2400 99
pacientes de 7 países europeos que
habían sufrido previamente un infarto de
miocardio y se le asignó de forma
aleatoria el recibir el tratamiento
o la polipíldora después de seguir a los
pacientes durante una media de tres años
los resultados fueron concluyentes la
adherencia al tratamiento mejoró y se
redujo un 24% el riesgo de nuevos
problemas problemas cardiovasculares
graves como un ictus un infarto de
miocardio no mortal o la
revascularización urgente en pacientes
que recibieron la píldora frente a los
que recibieron un tratamiento separado
de forma habitual la edad promedio de
los pacientes fue de 76 años y el 31 por
ciento eran mujeres los participantes
del estudio un 77 9% tenían hipertensión
un 57,4 por ciento diabetes y un 51 3%
antecedentes de tabaquismo raúl bueno
marina y también es que las enfermedades
cardiovasculares son la primera causa de
muerte en el mundo este suv esto según
la organización mundial de la salud que
supone esta unidosis para las personas
que padecen de estas dolencias karina y
raúl casi 10 y 18 millones de personas
mueren cada año por estas dolencias por
este tipo de enfermedades a nivel
mundial recordemos que en la actualidad
según los organismos de la salud la edad
promedio de un primer infarto de
miocardio es ahora de 65 6 años de edad
para los hombres y 72 para las mujeres
los investigadores de este estudio
llevan 15 años investigando alrededor de
esta polipíldora y es que según los
datos menos del 50 por ciento de los
pacientes con enfermedades crónicas
toman la medicación de forma adecuada
muchas veces debido a que tienen que
tomar varias pastillas al día y por esto
los científicos están desarrollando esta
aunque es una unidosis una sola dosis
ante la complejidad de tratamientos con
varias pastillas y la falta de aire día
de de adherencia perdón llegaron a
probar hasta 50 tipos distintos de
medicamentos para desarrollar esta
polipíldora que no fue de una tarea
fácil según dicen el principal
investigador del estudio señaló que los
hallazgos de la polipíldora podrían
convertirse en una parte integral de las
estrategias para prevenir eventos
cardiovasculares pero hay que otros
riesgos que siguen jugando un papel en
contra de este tratamiento por ejemplo
pacientes que padecen obesidad
tipo 2 o hipertensión esto es lo que
dijo en un comunicado
los hallazgos del estudio secure
sugieren que la polipíldora podría
convertirse en una parte integral de las
estrategias para prevenir eventos
cardiovasculares en pacientes que han
sufrido un infarto al simplificar el
tratamiento y mejorar la adherencia este
enfoque tiene el potencial de reducir el
riesgo de enfermedad recurrente y muerte
cardiovascular a escala mundial y es que
dentro de la comunidad científica a
rahola algunas personas sí que
criticaron este tipo de fármacos de una
sola dosis fija diciendo que no es
adecuada para este tipo de pacientes que
en muchas ocasiones requieren
tratamientos personalizados tras sufrir
un infarto para otros la polipíldora que
ya está disponible en 25 países de todo
el mundo podría facilitar el acceso a
pacientes de bajos ingresos donde
recordemos que ocurre en el 80% de las
muertes por enfermedades
cardiovasculares y que por temas
económicos no pueden adquirir una gran
cantidad de medicamentos para estas
dolencias teniendo así un tratamiento en
una sola píldora raúl claro marina y más
allá también digamos de lo económico
pues es más fácil un tratamiento de una
sola pintura que tres o muchas bueno
cambiando de tema una noticia que viene
sonando en las últimas semanas y es que
la agencia de naciones unidas advierte
de la sequía en el cuerno de áfrica que
pone a 22 millones de personas marinas
en riesgo de morir de hambre así de raúl
y es que ya veníamos diciendo no cómo
está la relación entre la salud pública
la salud global con el cambio climático
con estos fenómenos meteorológicos
adversos que están estrechamente ligados
y que nos afecta a nuestra salud a la de
millones de personas la escasez de
lluvias en áfrica ha provocado la peor
sequía en 40 años y ha grabado las
condiciones de hambruna en países como
etiopía kenia y somalia agravando
también la desnutrición persistente e
incrementando enfermedades derivadas por
ejemplo de una pobre alimentación o de
la inocuidad de los alimentos adquiridos
que allí se encuentran según la ms se
trata de una emergencia sanitaria
compleja con más de 80 millones de
personas padeciendo inseguridad
alimentaria en el cuerno de áfrica y es
que la falta de lluvia hace que estas
personas tengan un débil sistema
inmunitario como por no poder adquirir
alimentos de buena calidad o que por
ejemplo tomen agua contaminada o no
puedan lavar sus alimentos de forma
adecuada generando brotes de
enfermedades como el sarampión el cólera
o la meningitis el director de la ms
advirtió de la proliferación de estas
enfermedades en medio de esta grave
sequía
en burkina faso el extremo norte de
camerún chad malí níger y el noreste de
nigeria más de 33 millones de personas
están necesitadas y hay 67 millones
desplazados debido al conflicto la peor
sequía en 40 años y brotes de
enfermedades el año pasado más de 3600
personas en sahel murieron de cólera y
la transmisión de fiebre amarilla es la
más alta en 20 años las campañas de
inmunización interrumpidas debido al cob
y 19 han llevado a una mayor transmisión
del sarampión y la poliomielitis
derivada de la vacuna bueno marina
gracias por toda la información de esta
manera entonces llegamos al final de la
sección de salud por el día de mañana
por supuesto con más saludamos a nuestra
segunda invitada al día